dream will wait let's get the tweeze pop
oh yeah it's a start
you'll have my camera until I feel like
I don't need this to go see great good
good good
yes sir and we are Lara
Happy New Year and welcome to 2020 and
the aisle or podcast and the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 140 there's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day and
today we've got PS 5 to debut at CES
Vince Zampella and EA the value of game
pass and Phil's fences latest interview
to discuss so we gonna get right into it
so let's introduce the four horsemen of
gaming the original Lords here of the
round table
my co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of reviews and the half
of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict are you going sir doing
pretty good I was tired but I woke up a
little early to make sure I wasn't it
energized well this is making it guys
but you know what we'll see though we'll
see about getting it as genuine
energized before the show I did I press
the button see that the IV I'm gonna add
your name is fitting what have you been
playing sir over this over this long
break um let's see
I played a lot of Phoenix point but
playing a lot of destiny I've been
playing a lot of Pokemon yeah I've
realized there's a lot of bull Pokemon
online like thought that I'm just like
how you expect me to beat this thing
like so you come along though I will
fight the vibe you gave me before like
it was mad easy you wasn't really
feeling it like you in pocket now oh you
know that the game's still trash like
the haze
but I enjoy the competitive side uh like
I didn't realize like Pokemon
competitive is like crazy you know
exactly what to do or if you do
something too soon you're just getting
wiped you get destroyed okay so the
competitive scene is dead so it's been a
shot the Phoenix but that's another game
pass for PC right now right yeah it's
in-game pass for PC King I'm gonna tell
you right now and of course we have our
most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the sastra
Damas mr. offline profile Illuminati and
Lord patron of the I bake my man smooth
Lord sovereign now we're doing sir Happy
New Year now now so don't like is now
you're in our world so don't like the
fact that he's been up for a couple of
hours in which is right he might not he
might he might not have the energy to
fight us for that know what I do those
that I get up now you know breakfast or
whatever and I'm you know a beer with a
game a couple of hours so that's what I
do
you got a longer time the game now
coerced at Harbor works for you
what have you been doing during your
time officer I actually got to finish
some games where I come from the games
that's what's amazing for me so I
finally finished plague tale I mean this
narrative is fantastic the gameplay
stuff is very it's very basic sort of
gameplay like in terms of like stealth
and stuff like that I've been ready to
write home about
oh but those I mean those games from
focus Home Interactive man that's one
that's one company I wish Microsoft
would kind of have their eye on because
like when you look at plague tale that
game is gorgeous absolutely gorgeous
game the narrative is great the
characters are great it's just you look
at it and you know if they had a little
more dough like a little more dough
everything that they do that game like
vampire there is another game that they
made this cool in terms of narrative
greed for child as focused home because
we've been following focus hole for a
while say the last minute mentions and
every time we go to their showings yeah
I would say them one see and a couple of
line rebounds incredible once every time
we go to their booths and we do see
stuff it's always great products great
products as does you know they're on a
smaller scale yeah we're gonna pick up
anybody else like oh not even
necessarily pick up that publisher right
that's a big that's a big gap but it
like a snowball like the smaller devs
that are making these games like that
would fantastic and so that and I also
got to finish gears finally you finally
got to that ending part I mean it's
gears it's more years um it's it's
polished 2 gears as has never been it
run beautifully looks beautiful the
action is fun but when they corrected us
know hold on out in one second I'll stay
say in a so Bo dick joke mid plate still
focus home OData publisher yeah okay got
you guys okay guys could you could you
continue
um so um yeah man like I I enjoyed it
but I was at the end I felt it was a
little short maybe I don't know maybe I
just because the way I was playing it I
just I felt like it was I wanted a
little bit more in terms of gameplay um
well it was fine it was fine it's
beautiful it's the most polished version
I think the biggest criticism I get for
that is I felt like the ending could
have been a little bit different in
terms of boss was okay yeah that was
because that was just a cheesy y89 I
don't know yeah it could I think they
wanted to highlight other aspects at the
end of the game you know what I mean but
you know we gotta play that kognito cuz
you you're on the third at I'm I gotta
get it done I gotta go I gotta stop PSA
cuz the last the fourth act only takes
like an hour
to do what
which one is we have they said what's
Canon and they know they are never
brought that up you know you know to be
cannon I want to do it again like we had
the good team it was me you and I think
you are being a dick I mean good car and
wanna God was Jack and I like the way I
was using Jack and I like that squat it
was just us three this is getting us
three together psyche I don't want to
play it by myself with the AI doing
foolishness
I want to play with y'all y'all say that
way across since uh you know I know kid
smooth got nothing to do cuz his team
got I think you really should play co-op
because they were moments in that game
he is dumb as hell blade XA come to
switch
[Music]
eg with the $50 super chat to start off
there wow thank you so much brother
couldn't get you guys before the
holidays but Happy New Year Lords
enjoy your games and consoles and stop
banging
on that plastic I hate in the world that
is the goal my brother thank you so -
okay you should be in super check
reading self now it's 1:00 p.m. so like
before intros with the glasses after
inches without the glaze video crap
covered every - no Brad I think you own
or something the card box to an addict
they win it we already together we gonna
do it we finished up listen to X it's
not gonna happen
what are you doing right now is he's
shifting blind
Oh what he's doing is he knows both of
them they're not gonna be in a safer
home because I wanna play with you guys
and when all around we can get it done
Erica's gonna be at work cogs gonna be a
work is the mix of my pop up on this
chord we sit there like man let's play
some on let's play some some gears let's
finish that this need to be done
destiny added you I do need to do a
night down
I could I play Gears 5 on X cloud at
work with both of them home and the
other one listen in two years I want
teller ask him the same question play me
in that game he started off with me than
he that's not just the backlog that game
don't exist anyway you you know when you
could play that game king when our ways
out to comes out
No I'm near the end of either one of
those premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King are you doing sir oh
good
so delicious yesterday he's posting all
right oh destiny you know I'm such a
fraud I was playing soccer I thought I
was looking at all these posts right so
I picked that up and you know have the
resume evils I see you this time off
right now I'm going play did ain't
happen you know what I played this whole
time off destiny everyday certain bosses
I'd love to see you put fight on checker
oh no you don't know you don't I have
one guy tell me that it took him 90
minutes to beat a regular boss about the
first because there's no way in hell I'm
trying to it took five strains to beat
the monkey bars dude no listen
I saw a kid smooth stuff and I tell you
kids move is the most entertaining
person on the Internet
I don't care what nobody say you can go
back to I hope his videos that a million
views right now cuz you should be is the
funniest video that I've ever seen in my
life yeah yeah actually yes he threw his
controller against the wall so bad
that office alarms no mistake my boy tip
Dom isn't a super chat with the Canadian
dollar super chat pick up to the iron
door panels New Year's salute you
supposed to give us the temperature tip
dumb you always give it to temperature
again what is it - 35 what is it oh it's
that warm over there smack and polar
bears god bless bless well you know it's
just been destiny and I thought I was
gonna get something else done but I've
been watching my son play on a couple of
games because he got game past and this
kid has literally gone nuts
um and I can look at all the stuff he
does because Microsoft sends you like
readout on muneerah parent over the the
kids account Wow they tell you
everything that they're doing down to
the minutia down to the hour in a minute
that they're doing it what game who text
them you know what what's that about did
they go to browse any sites what sites
would be browsing and you know he can't
because that's that part is locked and
stuff like that if it's only 8 years old
but I didn't know that it was so
detailed the parent took parental
control yes now Microsoft allows you to
have over how the child interacts with
this gaming device and everybody is you
know usually afraid of their children
gaming because it's slow opens like an
open space you don't know if he's in a
chat room or whatever's going on and you
can monitor itself and I really think
that should be expressed more and talked
about more because it's a safe
environment for your child because you
can literally monitor every last second
or what he does and if you feel that
he's playing Fortnight too much you can
stop it right there from your phone oh
my god shut his joint now all right no
more for tonight you can limit the hours
that he's going to play certain games
and in this is a lower board this is not
allowable and I think that's fantastic
it gives me peace of mind as a parent
okay all right so a lot of people always
ask me you know those are they look
expensive
that's David and it look like MPC for
rainbows white King but um everybody
always ask me you know do I collect toys
and I have these toys probably for 15 20
years right um he says it behind me and
I said well I have a statue that's
coming in and when that statue comes in
it's part of the DC line I'm going to do
those toys with the statue a pause so
you guys can see exactly other stuff
that I hold and I collect because not
everybody collects statues you know a
lot of people is onto figures and stuff
like that like this acara
that i have that i was showing cog and
everybody before you know the show
fire as well but here is a classic to
chat welcome to the new year I LP this
is X Lord dirty D oh yeah 30 1982 from
Yellowknife oh my god wrestling penguins
it's not even pain with man that's like
from here on out I'm gonna consider
everyone in Canada a superhero well
I can't with what those are the people
that you take to that you know you ever
see that slapbox fight thing they got
the toughest skin so you go in there
with a group Canadian definitely win
their fight breaking down parental
controls and all that good stuff and of
Tyler says all I care about King is if
you got that world break a hook yet oh
okay so you world breaker Hawke didn't
come out yet but if you're talking about
gladiator Hawk the one where he's on top
of the like giant squid thing yeah
that's that's also coming in the middle
to have that coming too I'm probably
like I think it's like ten statues just
month this comes out the ice queen
gaming she's like it's cold in the UK
where I live I feel there's a negative
22 cold lord Cognito spray never illness
in the Roman ILP not telling what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
before I even start I just realized we
even through intros what Oh your salute
I want it first of all you get anything
I want his first one salute y'all it's
good to be back talking to my bro let's
get some aisle P and logos in the chair
put the logos to the chair you I only
match for 2020 exactly I don't
crushed-up though your shield up you're
insane so 118 in the chat looking real
good but you know first was good to be
back talking game
yeah will admit King we talked about
this in a I thought it did feel weird
that we that week we wasn't here I like
I feel like routine so you solve that
it's not the IOP logo Sunday from like a
lost puppy okay wise like you're
supposed to be doing like you cheating
like you're getting away with something
I know I'm I did I probably went back to
sleep after I realize you know
that's not there that whole time and
this is like the des singing period of
time that I'm up with all the energy
that energy was focused on doing a
perfect score in nightfall or no I was
being nice running people through
certain parts of raids Mike you let me
sure preview through men you've had all
kinds in this game I need you folks
straight to the podcast is supposed to
be over I gotta go you guys destiny van
just rock it out get my obelisk or a
level 11 apparently it looks like
Imperium foundation is what I'm hearing
is going to be the new trials we're
building the new trials we see on PC
because I don't play destiny on PC right
um do when you fly to earth and you try
to access the earth I'm always a mess
hold on probably oh yeah y'all you got
to do tricks you got to keep log coming
back sometimes you can take eight times
to get that obelisk or bunch of your
we're shout to damage from our bungee
where the Community Managers that's one
of the fixes it's also in the tower
sometimes the one that the obelisk
that's in the tower that one you have to
keep coming back everyone's but that
one's not as bad as the tower l 1x up my
biggest problem is yeah is definitely
the earth because every time I go down
like man okay I got a level this up so
any time I get a chance to get in there
I level it up and grab all about - yeah
you got a gravity like when I was say
it's focused almost on the EDC first get
that up to level 11 with the resonance
get all the little things by all the
little things that low rank ups cuz
they'll make the sundial better so when
you get run down you get more drops so
do that joint it takes a game of would
say yeah ma it's okay you couldn't even
imagine loaning out the EDC on console
yeah it's gotta be it's it's more I
really think we need is those SSDs man
you know what the King said I go out did
a storm will give me an SSD I'm gonna
bawl out how much do I got me a little
samsung portable join first bike oh if
I'm gonna play not master race I'm gonna
need an SSD question this you should get
audible one right now when I'm standing
in the store and I'm looking at them
they told me that little portable joint
is not ideal for my console and they got
one ideal for the complement and they
give you a little chart I shout out the
best by for making dumping smart and I
was like okay because I was gonna give
you not just shout out the best by for
making dumb people smart because I will
go in there and purchase some joint
thing and I'm smart now I got a chart
just for me so I know exactly where I
fit in so I don't get home and be like
oh like I did with that headset and I
didn't have a jack for my smartphone oh
my god I gotta take this back so yeah so
shadow chief Tommy see I'm sure it can't
be worse than outer worlds loading
screen you know what but see I'm playing
on SSD on Xbox that's what I like so
it's fine I'm doing everything with no
umbrella more naturally it to me it's
very comparable to pee I used I use that
that portable one to you connect to the
USB and it's fine like you what you can
also do that maybe a little bit cheaper
you can get a bigger SSD is that you get
and it you get an internal you buy like
a cheap encasement on Amazon yes well
then you buy an actual PC SSD and did
you know that you would put inside of a
case but you just put it in the
encasement and you're good to go
oh the fourth day he said don't let them
lie to you King yeah it was xbox branded
the one that they told you to get but
the one I got the same someone when you
compared to was like 160 something like
that well I know I spend like I'm like a
blessed man over now because I might the
next generation consoles are gonna come
so I know
- crazy this is just so that when I do
cross play and I play which is at least
tolerable okay 30 frames is one thing
but the 30 frames on top of the slow
load screens like people to understand
on PC you know destiny is you start the
match you go like you guys let me go to
the fridge I'm gonna go to the bathroom
we fly oh no no PC we like yeah I said
the match what's going ready I'm like oh
you don't get no brakes like you used to
you know they're the ghazal joint but
yeah that's what I would say but I've
been doing good I want to shout out one
Lord real quick
no Michael mercy man yo he did the
gaming ninja proud man this guy I ope he
took like he's an 80s toy and video game
connoisseur you know he did the storm
shadow joy shot like the Lords out
please watch that I put it up on Twitter
shout - Michael mercy we working on
something with him hopefully we'll get
him in the realm as well pretty much I
got something I'm you might be um a
little bit happy that I'm getting see if
I can pull that up and hopefully I'm
still winning the bid right now I'm
gonna go to bids hopefully they didn't
you know knock me out but right now I'm
still winning right now okay I'm still
the highest bidder foot I think you can
see it right I'm still a height is
better right now for this snake eyes oh
yeah snake eyes with timber then I'm
trying to win a storm shadow coming to
you oh I can't wait about to be on Kos
Fred yes well we know what mean you know
when that space that you comes out that
we both gonna pre-order controls are
finally done it is that time of the
month yet again to say thank you to all
of our wonderful supporters patrons and
YouTube subscribers and give a little
bit back to the community so let's start
out with our patreon subscribe
say thank you to them um first off of
course mr. you fraud it on us a little
bit uh mr. J meds lords thank you for
your support and of course a forever
patron Lord Cory lydic 8k Lord whiskey
bottle by Lord slow-mo backslap thank
you sir
Lord
H P 33 thank you sir mm-hmm solo course
followed by Lord Nintendo Direct you
don't get MPD is not good enough q ik
seven masters thank you sir for love is
the loop followed by Lords are oh thank
you sir and we have a new patron Oh Lord
novocaine F we have North fastback 67 68
whoa my man l Gina building and followed
by of course the Lord who loves his
Nintendo switch topic I love
[Laughter]
we purposely don't put the the timestamp
on the switch stop coming back we have
lured back a Bordeaux next up we have
the Lord of gamestop in one of the most
positive laws in our realm we have the
Lords of gaming net Lord undead 36 next
up we have Lord linchpin thank you next
we have another new patron Lord this is
government can't say anything let's say
Lord he adds 13 I won't say I just
appreciate followed by the Lord of the
wall of bill it was - it was hilarious
because he's like it was like exactly's
proven it's worth it's proven it works
everywhere next up next up we have the
Lord who is definitely from not overseas
savvy press class
salute followed by family to the realm
the chocolate a man himself next up we
have a very first patron Lord Michael
Lugo aka monkey punch thank you cking
notice they didn't mention any Nintendo
games they play it over to break next up
we have the Lord of this dream team
Lords now doe himself thank you sir no
cards out your cup this is what I got oh
[Music]
that's hot that's hot at feast hold on a
second
I lost my I'm looking at this damn
statue of I lost my kobera himself Lord
loaded pixels thank you Happy New Year
brother
next up of course we have Lord Tao Zi Qi
thank you sir followed by Lord J Pereira
thank you sir Lord Davis thank you
shouted out King this week he picked up
spider-man all four kings oh that's
quite a good like Yoda salute to the
king man this is one of his best said
it's the best superhero game he's ever
played yeah I know listen I stand behind
that game that's game of the year all
that other stuff that was even
mentioning
mm-hmm all right and of course we have
last but certainly not least our brother
from definitely across the pond Lord
that singing always ahead of us on the
street shut up the double-barrel good
lord
boom hello everyone on this glorious
panel brother boom shadow not gonna talk
I got my white office dog so what's
going on so that's that for patreon
subscribers thank you so much guys we'll
get back to the to the giveaways in a
second but before that I want to say
thank you so much to our YouTube
subscribers yes get into that so in no
particular order first up we got Lord
bet stars finest thank you so much for
the support I see a month of subscribers
in yeah any woman from the peasant to
look Justin seem right yeah I see the
justice in the chat working your way up
the hierarchy
around degrees in the Lord s single
subscriber take you some stop we have
liqueurs Lord Philly Eagle
[Laughter]
thank you I love their music thank you
so much yes sir and I repeat the biggest
supporter of the Nintendo school style
he's out there school tech talk YouTube
channels oh he has some great articles
on log now that is my tech brother right
now please support him
next up we have North Jonathan P thank
yo game by tracer I'll be gaming for
over 40 years
[Laughter]
mad Mario
[Laughter]
we are Lord pixel bit J thank you
support be very knowledgeable brother
very village and of course my lord
gaming forte double supported thank you
so much
see those emojis are looking good y'all
yes sir yes sir right
he said the German Xbox the God of War
i'ma tell you something right now
if ever on this earth God who all comes
to Xbox you must read to the real salute
the ladies yo set Ravenna with the $20
super chair aka mrs. boomstick happy New
Year to all the lords hope it's a great
year for everyone first of all I lost
Luke to the lady of the room no we are
very thankful because we could be heard
do to you it might be even better summer
thank you for your blessing and even
though you really appreciate that
because I can't be a buddy cop movie
without my buddy so due to this amazing
moment one of the best supporters of the
round yes
lady Joe sitt we have Lord Titus right
this is like the best wrestling name
ever Lord Titus right sound like the
dude Ultimate Warrior's to come out on
Saturday rested challenging beat above
may take up to the bow no you better see
that meaning is really different that's
a real different energy
we are the original Lords of the round
0lp but not least the lord of the stream
team building stuff tomorrow what the
hell everybody subscribe to us on
youtube if you have not look at that
button right there right below the
string a little subscribe button click
on that subscribe to the iron Lords
podcast we have a number of different
levels you can start out with the bronze
or the gold or silver you know what you
do get access to those emojis and and a
bunch of discounts on teespring
oh the good stitch ain't taking this
thing out going down without a fight
Soulja Boy console before I get a
smashes bushes bushes
fantastic weekend salute bro you better
get you back one hour and on none of
that BS man we go go go - good data we
don't get thrown out
hilarious that think that was the best
episode ever
they had to do it in bars in a parking
lot we go back to the other spot don't
know why I have better lighting $10 gift
cards give away let's go and the winner
of the $10 gift card is Lord HB 33 next
we have our $20 gift card giveaway and
the winner of our $20 gift card giveaway
a No Lord Jesus thank you for the
support sir we have our teespring
giveaway of our teespring giveaway is oh
yes a new Lord Lord Novocain no no
dropping off the bag things pay off
immediately
salut no vacated of a new name new
winning okay salute to all of our
supporters thank you so much guys for
doing this I know it's a little
long-winded and thanks to you guys this
long-winded because the let's keep
getting longer and longer much love to
all you guys much appreciate it it
really does help every little bit of
support is being here every Sunday helps
a lot so thank you so much salute to the
realm love to give back real quick
before we jump in as well I want to
shout out the entire log neck team man
this will give it up to them yo the only
ignant is the only side I saw
continuously posting throughout the
holiday everybody else took off log net
was partners moving man I am so blessed
shout to dizzy shout out to everyone on
the team man Josh reading undead I mean
it one of the most tremendous most I've
ever seen the month of December I mean
we damn near double triple our output
ever or highest output and like I said
it's just more things to come and so
salute like I said that was actually our
second highest since e3 you know I'm
saying
so I'm yet I was tremendous and I said
if you're not going to lose a game and
dot never not going to log net you know
then 2020 is the time y'all we are
moving out here it's a lot going on so
salute to everybody on the team every
single article opinion pieces tech
pieces movie pieces everything
everybody's moving everybody everybody
who solves more everybody's contributing
and building something for the community
grassroots Charleroi it's y'all I gotta
lords it around man y'all make it happen
we got some more applications coming in
is going down man but I'm gonna wrestle
an aficionado I want somebody who
follows wrestling on fire because you
know part of IOP is you know we play
that wrestling so we really hardcore
into that stuff
absolutely we are going to move on a lot
of show so well yeah let's get into
these topics man so there's a lot been
going on since we've been gone but also
some new developments so I'm wondering
is Sony teasing the rebuttal to fill
dominus and the game is coming right now
Sony website there's been a teaser for
at the CES 2020 press conference which
is taking place Monday you know I'm
saying and the website reads the future
is coming you have to read the whole
thing the vision of the future honestly
believe that revealed they've only up to
this point they've done the wire you
know thing but they haven't done an
official reveal of it so the question is
in reference to that non playstation
products but there is a woman then this
was coupled by Cory bar log man he's
been on Twitter tweeting up a storm and
he's also at the PlayStation we'd like
to switch
I think this is like he's gonna
experience his first CES in little over
a week hopefully I see some robots so at
the end of the day this has led people
to speculate is CES the reveal for the
place yeah and if it's the perfect
rebuttal so I wouldn't get the loads in
alright you could go for this can't wait
clearly talk about big curveball log is
only there to tell Oh God awards go to
the PCs that is the absolute wrong crowd
you want to bring your week tech - okay
you got 8k television you got high high
caliber cameras you got all this super
tech there here you go with this
underpowered box that you're bringing it
and you think it's supposed to be well
oh just because there's Sony you think
you go take over the show just because
you're announcing are you out of your
mind
see this is when your strategy goes
wrong this is when you have the wrong
person in the right place GG PU PS phase
replay set your fans reach it because
they should so I feel that that's the
absolute wrong forum for you to release
that tech now now maybe this is a proper
forum for you to release the vr if you
have an upgrade of VR with the camera
and stuff inside I think that forum fits
that because who is your demographic
that you're looking at see my girl
Microsoft's demographic that they were
looking at was all those gamers that was
looking at the game awards show Oh
between all the the if def stranding is
gonna win all the hope lot I was
surrounding it so many people was
watching it for those reasons right and
then you got surprised with the
Microsoft joint so that level of attack
was crazy
those views is crazy how many people is
gonna be really watching the CES yeah
like I mean you know it's gonna get
covered by the media
but it's going to be a footnote it's not
gonna be something that's going to stand
out and I think if in a whole Cory ball
log is not they're trying to you know
war to the PC oh yes my PC at CEO of er
is you know what and that's probably it
God of War VR I hope they don't waste
their shot because it will be a weak
blow it it'd be like you punch you have
a punch the bully in the face I'm a
loser if it's VR like I'm officially
DeLuca don't lose it because a lot of
people want that B I want that VR he
says it's not the place for a console
review it's not because he should know
he's the official CES do he knows that
for for fat [ __ ] or people in looking at
that so have you ever punched a bully in
her face like you thought this was your
time I mean to be fair
Microsoft pretty much revealed the Xbox
one X through digital foundries do that
so like I feel like this this event is
his on is on a better scale than digital
foundry so because all the tech industry
gonna be looking at this event yeah I
agreed that it's it doesn't feel like
it's it's the venue for this right at
all but then all of a sudden now with
the with the assumption that they're
gonna say something about PlayStation
yeah all of us watching now right it's
all of a sudden does become an event for
us right just because of that now where
it would fail is if the PlayStation
isn't the center of attention
if the admits if it's a side kind of
announcement along with whatever the aka
TV is or whatever else born if it's not
PlayStation centric completely let's
make your own make a Playstation about
this he says CES general I attendance is
almost three
of III I know I definitely get that but
generally the beador a lot of the market
yeah a lot of them its TV tech it's
refrigerated like tech though like we
can't avoid that their new TVs that they
can't do they can't do a cake
why are you gonna bring your
underpowered joint they're like why are
you bringing a Volvo to a Lamborghini
show take your volvo volvo it they've
been they've had someone watching
because some patents come out there i
don't know how true any of them are
right but they obviously the next vr
thing this other thing with these
controllers where it links up like it's
almost like an i can ex cloud o-p-s now
centric controller thing that's a
portable thing but not a portable thing
like they have a couple of hardware
patents that could be realities that
maybe they talked about here that would
make more Corey but up there with the VR
glasses talk about God listen because
that's central to they did their
movement going forward that VR they but
they're not going to be our announcement
over their actual console this is a much
Sony who are you I want a butt plug
first the pacifier guy attachment to the
yes you know the pacifier maybe go in
depth about the pacifier you hear
dropping knowledge OG xbox was announced
at CES time in place is a different time
I don't think it's gonna get I think
that you know they're gonna show the
specs they might show game running on it
obviously it's gonna be called the ps4
there's no reason to hold that but I
still think they're gonna have their own
event to like break it more down break
like jazz
we knew yeah I could see Sony using CES
just to say ps5 is coming this year as
part of their tech reveal maybe a
controller and the type of the day of
the PS 5 reveal of it they could set it
up you know I'm saying we know AMD's
gonna beat it right yeah you bring your
wheat geek nerds is gonna do to your
weak tech that you don't up to you loony
are not gonna be impressed with 9.2
terrified are you bringing this 9
teraflop machine here Xbox machine PS 5
it's got nine tariffs what am I supposed
to play the executive mark Cerny in
check don't never show new hall went
through a cheap trailer they treat
hardware is great technology at the
marks executive in IO feet sad to do
money I think you're onto something so
don't show your cheap check there and
show it in the corner in the bushes
listen just put a little sign that we
over here because nobody care yo dudes
over there looking at the new 8k joint
and they say well can my playstation
know we all know both of them fraud a
little bit with it not Microsoft talk
about that no no when they do know
they're gonna do up as a k still
pictures listen
then okay Microsoft can't do it all
right so maybe you might get a still
picture it ain't a that people put out
and you can see right but I'm not gonna
fall for those dudes - those dudes ain't
gonna be at the CES show evil you know
keep 12 teraflops waiting and keep it at
don't bring your little 9 teraflops they
think Oh - why we shaving what have we
got - man we're teraflop shaving now
trying 980 ways I just I'll be
disappointed if the PS 5 is not the
center of attention okay if that's not
the the the the main crux of their whole
press conference I want to jump in real
quick cuz I was evil I do a lot of
teraflop share being in our DNA 2.0 vs.
1.0 saving on the internet but I want to
shine up the market sellers man he
actually he disagrees but but you know
what we will let you jump in because
you're not playing on a nine do it -
Marcus you said that the P he thinks the
PS 5 revealed will be in February which
we showcase the specifications of the
console as well as upcoming games to be
released on the platform look I don't
know what to believe just yet you know
balrog being there though that is the
only thing where I'm like cuz normally I
agree with King like I don't know
I think CES has lost that flavor we're
used to be four for gaming it's far for
gaming is concerned but but to be fair
before you keep going um Microsoft
announced they stuff with the video game
awards so maybe Saudi trying to do
something different - right that's fine
you know I'm saying but we have to admit
the video game awards is on the upward
trend like video games as a medium has
now like soup at almost surpassed movies
or Lisa on the same level it comes to it
right no is it faster right so
that we gotta say you know what I was I
was that was a filled ominous move we
all respect it you know we also try us
out what is Sony gonna do they got to do
something that they've really been this
the first time Axel's been aggressive
right so far to set off the generation
line boy that's what we doing [ __ ]
bullies agree you're not the biggest
thing we need to take into this though
what's up the 12 is not a flavor chance
still about the game sir but anyway yeah
pom-pom and I'll see what it is when 80
boy they come face you come face BK ten
hours which and the funny thing is
people running around with this twelve
teraflop series X but AMD doesn't have a
twelve teraflop rDNA twelve teraflop
graphics caught on a market or at least
one yet
smh everything speculation not tell this
severe actually face the the rumors that
have been have come out again it is
speculation but from the sources that
have leaked out the digital fat fertile
tried to deal a game let's give it up to
deal again because people have to deal a
look has been going hard not saying and
he's began attacked and everything that
he's been putting out in reference to
the specs and reference to our DMA 2.0
being on the Xbox series X and so many
specs coming out being non teraflops and
not R D not appeal also the variable
ratings out the mods on that there's a
lot of I wants a proprietary check my
specific tech in the series X that is
being validated by a lot of insiders
that really are close to this thing so
again we will wait until final
confirmation but these insiders aren't
to be trusted so I see what you're going
for face but right now I do tend to
believe these guys that are putting this
stuff in phase
I'm info troll mode it's like okay I I
feel what you're saying I do think it
was the upward trend for video game
words as opposed to the downward trend
of cs4 showing video game stuff so I
agree with y'all on that the dingoo
Corey bottle octane definitely makes me
a little like okay what are you doing
there why are you a CES is it gonna be
something that's too short and then be I
gotta hear this Jonathan be fine I love
super chat thank you brother
Sony crown jewel was getting revealed
that a refrigerator column with a smart
toaster teraflops at CES is named let's
all come together and have a moment of
silence for Kings first super chat right
of the year
I work even with the shades and
afternoon will hold a kick to dizzy kick
these twelve teraflops to play kart
races and ground it you know the biggest
thing that we gotta take into this was
how PlayStation people are gonna be
playing on some n64 next year we got
Brad they're all I gotta say is PC
master-race how you put it I'm better
I'm here I'm here did come out and it
was whistling past the grave but we know
the free to those consoles actually MB
stock went up from penny stocks up to 48
dollars sharing and I'm so upset that I
didn't get in on their stocks when it
was low I am so glad they saying some
slanders thing is people look you guys
don't have to believe dealer you guys
don't have to believe all the people you
totally talk about at the end of the day
if it comes out though that it is 12
teraflops as these people are reporting
we want to see means none of these
people gonna show them but I'm
documenting who's saying no you don't
say in my mind it is there but again we
will see but at the end of day here's a
deal real talk we got a watch if
anything y'all want to pay attention to
this week pay attention to the AMD
press conference pay attention to the
Sony press conference this weekend is
one of those two we're gonna see
something in reference to that so you
know at the end of the day I would say
that Sony has been unconventional so far
and reference to the PS file be they
debut
the sort of respect some of the specs at
that was it that wired article they did
you know I'm saying so you know what
that's it I guess my question to y'all
my throw it back and this is gonna be
interesting kind of like the poll but
you know what do you think is the best
video I may be the king
what do you think is the best venue for
them to do their own kind of event and
then rock it that way as opposed to Sony
we know the Sony we know controls a
narrative Sony L is cocky Sony we know
holds their own they beat of their own
drum they dictated pace right this this
remember it was a takeover then it was
then it was super ugly don't make Phil
gamba this mask and a Spencer drop super
ugly on your neck because right now if
you put out let's say you do this in a
situation where backfire it's going to
backfire they're showing things they
show in tech that is greater than your
tech there don't get lost in a source
control and narrative have their views
on I think more people were tuned into a
Sony live event that they're staging
that they're showing you the reveal of
the five opposed to CES and somebody
looking at the timeline it was like what
the PlayStation 5 got revealed they
showed it you know so I think they
should control the the narrative going
forward because right now on your heels
a degree dance so we got a fight our
super shot from a brat series X on par
with 2:27 D super Nvidia ain't worried
fawns with the scoop 2020 gonna be great
for gaming and Carl won't finish gears 5
until 2030 you know what you might be
onto something
what do you think I'm a king I think
they would have been better suited to
their own event you know people you
somebody if Sony that come on but like
stay tuned for a Sony event the future
is coming everybody knows what it is
everybody knows that it's gonna be a big
blowout you gonna have mark Cerny up
there talking all these numbers whatever
the case may be beating the show game
hmm they could do that within the press
conference up see yes they could
whatever point I would make as much
sensitive to do that we got close which
I'm not gonna ask solve a question but
just it's uh
but King Sony lost a means that the game
would you I can't say that they lost a
means at the game was they got smacked
you know how when they win win when
somebody take that white smacking you're
faced with a challenge you to a duel
you know they face a stun right now the
only time I've ever seen Sony that quiet
is when backwards compatibility is
announced exactly so we all know what is
the situation but I really believe that
you under some stage know now let's get
let me get face all shout the face man
and you know it's all fun and games to
be honest Microsoft needs to power
Vantage more than Sony until my source
can get their first party situation or
the guys better whole ps5 and clothes
and power to the Xbox area
hey what you say and listen Microsoft
does need the power I have to take away
that narrative but well again all we're
saying we're not talk about every rumor
that's coming out all we talking about
is the twelve teraflops and the rDNA 2.0
along with the variable rate shading
those are things from multiple sources
but to be honest face don't do you need
to know as 12 is bigger than that I
don't even care about power but it's
just so funny to say that toe is bigger
than that Microsoft should care about
power it's because throughout the whole
dis generation resolution they were
under powering in the beginning they had
the games right did that matter than
anybody knows when digital found you put
your games up and he was running at 720
and PlayStation was running at 1080p
nice and good let's not forget what
happened and you know the person that's
in charge right now failed ominous
Maximus Spencer um it's not gonna
concede
power cuz he understands that is a
driving point if you can take a bullet
point off the board remove the bullet
point off the board there's we even
heard about powers since the ex came out
so they can't talk about that and that's
nice
I don't listen I'm gonna buy both enough
Detroit he says six is bigger than four
teraflop and look what happened we're
going out and buy an xbox one axis just
to play right dad - what do you talk
about we we go talk like that didn't
happen like big figures of IGN were
going out just to play it on their ex
sporting an entire save files because it
was that much better on the end let me
ask you this question right had no
Kinect camera box had Microsoft put out
the X power against whatever to play say
let's say both came out PlayStation Pro
and the X at the same time and Microsoft
didn't lose the narrative as far as
resolution there was no resolution gate
was none of that stuff happening does
PlayStation get mind share oh we know
that that played a big part in it you
know and you know Russian you had the
games then he had the games and that was
at the end but what was that drought
that was going on with you in the
beginning you know licking your lips
again stuff like chapstick oh hey it's
always an honor to have a Sony executive
in our chair um we have duct tape 257
hundreds together place 2005 18
teraflops saluting us the behind the
scenes bark so you're always what we
want to get you back and get a proper
introduction on IOP no mark you remember
me last time
I just got a question man what type of
duct tape is it man you gotta give us
the full 101 man you can't just love
that it's March 30 so salute you but yes
I wanna bring it back you were painting
before you move on all right what'd you
say what really mark Cerny no he'll be
fine we clown it'll be funny but like
what what so I get what you going my
question is what do you say about the
Corey parlor what do you think he doing
it in again if you come in and you show
it what if it's since the end of God of
War
he's just been working
on a demo to show for psy I forgot the
next God award that's it yeah if you
drop that and it's in game right
whatever it's like nobody was or
whatever and it looks fantastic you're
gonna take over the conversation that's
one yeah so he has no reason to be there
other than to talk about something get
something gaming related per period
right
another thing Sony could do Sony we
knows Cory wants a smart toaster let's
be real here we're not going all adding
marks let me answered you he said the
tape is Gorilla Tape he said we didn't
cheap our own performance and because I
need that Gorilla Tape is unacceptable
like Johnny oh he's Crown boxer he's
coming for bugs we got to be realistic
here all right
Cory might just be going just cuz he's a
fan attack like I doubt it
why now with Cory lately you know saying
I keep it talking very what happens if
Cory's going for another company and not
Sony imagine once of course King
watching Cory is going for another
company and not Sony remember he put
that out too and I saw that tweet now
are you talking about it's is he going
to a Nintendo there can't be there again
right so you know what if what if there
is something cookin it cuz I don't know
you saw saw and a dick I showed you he
got a very nasty tweet from some Sony
fans about his kumbaya kumbaya he's too
buddy-buddy wit with Xbox and you know I
wouldn't be surprised if he's doing
something with them it was really nice
he actually screen captain so just out
of curiosity I doubt the
obviously but what happens if Cory comes
out there in shout out the clutch big
yeah he said if power doesn't matter
don't brag about your PC so so I do have
a question for the panel for the realm
what happens if it turns out that Cory
has been employed is a high position
initiative do you think the internet
will explode what explode I doubt it I
would say the procedure that happened is
like 5% maybe no Sonique it could be
petty about how they respond right what
if they just come out and say PS 5 399
by they would never do now and do it now
you know you so because you allow
Microsoft enough time to match price
like ok I think price is going to be the
last word drop because that's mean one
once you lock then type of thing after
they made a trip you know 399 right now
you then you just you just gave the
ballgame to feel like what are you crazy
you gave Tom Brady the ball back with
him I think that's where I think that's
where Lockhart comes in I don't think
that touches whatever whatever um you
know whatever other X is gonna be series
next is gonna be the manager question
right I'm with you and the boardroom
they do this bonehead move cuz you know
to them they own head moves or we're
giving it a name ok got you know
let's theoretically say that it is still
you know not 99 what do you think
Microsoft's responses this game what's
those what's just fills one straight
upstairs and say this is the time we can
bury him
um this is very embarrassing we can bury
them right now by locking them into
position and putting a lock hard right
under them with $2.99 and we can come
right above them well if the lockout is
severely underpowered with the four
teraflops do these news is talking about
you can come in at 199 bust a face wide
open is it sometimes I feel like Eve is
it in the in the real world and this is
one of those that this man won't go in
there for the jugular
you could I said yeah he's willing to
play around at that price next is gonna
be right before teh stuff let's go I
think they're going to show off a tech
demo of God of War on the PS 5 last year
they had a tech demo for GT sports
running at 8k just another forte theory
I've got a fight out super track from
Victor Sony announcing but there Oh
wasn't the Saudi announced of a thousand
Cinemax by it would be huge and worth it
happy new years to the best podcast you
know what both you you might be onto
something except for Victor I don't
believe you that wasn't that was not one
of the topics but I do think we needed
to talk about some time point of the
show the possibility of Sony by but
that's fourteen do you honestly believe
then I wants me to rationally think
about this that they were doing anything
with that nine teraflops an 8k I want
you to rationally think about that now
they probably had some super high power
pcs in the back doing some anycase stuff
no but that was a that was a PC that was
that was a multiple PC yeah
that please they were just showing you
tech that they was using for ray tracing
that they was trying to squeeze down
into this little non teraflop box and
they have not shown no tech has been
shown that they have any silicone with
that because they said it's supposed to
bleed you're gonna have a great summer
to sound like Oprah over you're gonna
have a first first of all anyone who is
buying into the Bethesda buyout rumor
give me what you are smoking I want
ain't nobody say that's factual but it's
still worthy what's funny all the rumors
I've seen all the rumors I've seen has
literally just been talking about the
studio that makes um the Elder Scrolls
online none of them have been Bethesda
but for some reason we are going with
the desert I have no clue how that
stopped because if you buy ZeniMax you
buy it all ZeniMax is the profit holder
for everything so if you want to buy
ZeniMax you gotta buy arcane you got a
mine I mean yeah you got to read that
super chair because he's definitely what
that's exactly what I'm talking about
mm-hmm how you gonna tell us to read the
super chair we got the super chat but
gamer by choice
let's let's let's let undead read there
load up here guy we get we already
overworked this way let's overworking
some articles out you make it my man
work too hard right now if ps5 is $3.99
at 9.2 its teraflops what should
lockhart be if for tariff loss I'm
thinking it needs to be $200 cheeping
the ps5 is half the power ok teraflops
is not a met processing power pts
teraflops not the end all and be all of
the console here mmm
just because you're talking RAW
processing power we're not talking about
what this console is capable of Lockhart
is gonna be at best is gonna be a 1440p
60 Plus FPS console that's what they're
going for here isn't that worth $200
cheaper than the police station file I
think so even if because I feel Xbox
Series ass will come in at 349 that's
where I've got this 349 SS he's cold up
there the series X because I don't need
cooling on my console because it could
be 1440p with 60fps plus upwards of that
framerate I believe and the reason I say
that is because that's a really good
deal and look people are are discounting
with these consoles across the board PS
5 Xbox services s everything is we are
getting mid-range PC power finally in
the console space for affordability you
get an Xbox series s4 349 that's 2 a
1440p at 60fps good luck finding a PC
that can do that for that price that's a
big deal here and I think the biggest
struggle they're gonna have with this is
differentiating this is our budget set
this is our high-end thread that's gonna
be the problem because
mom and paw are going to be like oh well
we want this one and the guy GameStop's
gonna be like this one or this one
that's gonna be their problem I don't
think they already explained and I'm
gonna refer to the the expert um they
have no problem with telling them what
is what at the store because their world
I think my personal opinion the Xbox
Series s between now and launch I think
that they'll be really promoting this
the series s more but those will be
promoting the X but don't want people to
see the the cheaper price over the power
of the most powerful system no expect
the heart no expect the hardcore to
already know that so let's still promote
it just not as much as the S I know who
you are who put those two dislikes I
could barely see it King so accidentally
hit the thumbs down but I'll correct it
your prediction on CES as a playstation
5 reveal point or dedicated own Sony
event would you do
okay so CES is an industry event it's
not a people are getting this confused
cuz they're like well Xbox Series X was
revealed at the Game Awards so maybe ps5
could be revealed as yes Game Awards is
still a public event where people are
got eyes on it right that thing got more
views than the Oscars this year public
was watching game worth CES is for
industry types and technology the much
is pretty much would be three used to be
just for the gaming industry yeah so
basically what I think they're gonna do
I think they will talk a little bit
about ps5 but they're not going to talk
about the box itself they're gonna talk
about the technology that is entailed
with the PS 5 I think they're gonna talk
about their SSD technology doing easing
and they might talk a little bit more
I'd say that I think a lot of the stuff
that's gonna be relevant to us is
console players it's gonna be at the AMD
presentation yeah
both these consoles are running a NZ
hardware thanks if people want to have a
better understanding of what its gonna
be like going forward for both these
consoles they should pay attention to
the AMD presentation if you're
interested in that side completely could
you agree with me that uh fill indominus
Maxima spencer might be on hand to give
a double back smack because somebody
just praised my game ethan out there he
could just do super again if i'm wrong
and i know that well because it's the
internet but i'm almost positive either
phil or someone from sony has been on
stage during CES events in regards to
AMD technology before i cannot but there
was a couple years ago yeah I think it
was Phil I couldn't remember right off
the top my head so it wouldn't be
outlandish to see someone from
PlayStation or Phil Spencer or anything
like that show up on the AMD stage like
hey this is what this means in terms of
console gaming because you gotta
remember cs4 AMD is also gonna be them
showing off their new lines of GPUs and
everything else so let me get that super
Chet Smoove at a $2.00 super chair thank
you so much sir the funniest man on the
Internet
no doubt yeah but Sony is inviting the
public to watch beaver stream and and I
know that they're asking people to watch
you know if you were stream but I
honestly believe is for the VR I think
they want more eyes on the VR do
something that Microsoft is not doing
okay because if you take if you
highlight your power and you take away
you know you can you show them that
Microsoft has a weakness if if they do
have a weakness going forward it's
definitely they have no VR presence at
all and Sony does have a VR presence so
if you want that tech to be sold and you
have to show it off in a great light
because how many people how many tech
heads is gonna get a hold of the noodles
Cloney VR and I'll help all for
president the people who bought that
loved it is selling in the millions and
that's how I told you something sold in
the millions I was fax on I'll just send
73 hit that like button you already know
listen we got to move on this is a good
topic we shall see this week but like
undead said pay attention you're like I
said Monday CES
attention to AMD section pay attention
to the Sony section let's see what
happens we gonna move on Lord sovereign
our Vince is moving in these EA streets
going no you know I Loki think that Lord
Cognito is a little hurt he couldn't
grab this topic before yeah I think he
was sleeping again I was like what when
you put it in a group like y'all bad I
didn't notice
yeah so Vince Zampella star continues to
rise at EA as the the CEO and Founder
Respawn Entertainment is now the head of
aid of dice la dice la previously was
just a support studio and now obviously
with the success of apex with the
success of titanfall actually and with
the success of Jedi fallen order thank
goodness EA is realizing that the the
sort of design ethos that Respawn
Entertainment utilizes in their studio
would work across the board for my
thinking beyond EA dice LA honestly all
the studios so my thinking is that
they're giving Vince Disick this
expanded role of power to sort of
oversee more studios and sort of get the
culture of respawn to sort of permeate
the rest of EA suit EA studios and I
think it's a fantastic move I think
respawn doesn't make bad games they have
not made a bunny defeated baby oh it
batting a thousand no I think this is a
fantastic move by them I think the fact
that now a you know dice la is probably
gonna be a rebranded to another I think
bin said it he's gonna they're gonna
rebrand it's not gonna be dice earlier
it'd be something else
and now that studio is gonna be manned
up in a way to be able to make its own
game rather than just support other
studios I think it's fantastic and
another thing they talked about is
something that um that respawn does in
terms of how they are how they sort of
work it I try the demo games and
something in the rapid prototyping I'll
let you expand out
rapid prototyping basically in a way
that they figured out to sort of get
working prototypes of gameplay of the
way a game is gonna feel not necessarily
look but get that up and running in a
way early on that you can tell if the
game is gonna be something good because
one of the big problems we've seen in it
with Studios in general but EA in
particular is that they'll get a year
into developing a game and then realize
it's not working it's not ready to be
they got more tools to the light but I
didn't it's worked with respawn so you
have it that's the thing like respawn if
something ain't working don't know two
months in three months in rather than
six months in mmm-hmm it matters it
matters to resources and matters to to
redirecting things so if they use this
sort of design ethos across all of a
gamers have a very short memory span
right we forget it pretty quickly and I
think we like a redemption story and I
think one of the big stories for next
gen I think is the overall EA redemption
story hopefully that permeates to
Bioware and you know and and things like
that we'll see but I think all around
it's a fantastic move yeah let me get
undead real quick oh my no he's mute all
these unmuted he's back yeah okay now
you have a fantastic article on this on
what website the Lords of gaming jobs
you know for people that don't really
you know they're new viewers to this
they're gonna assume that you have like
really bad memory cognate because you're
I was like what what I just need to be
reminded you know continued fantastic
article or non dead and um you wanted to
first to break it you know as far as the
whole Vincent pellet thing ei dice like
what's your whole take on this whole
situation
look people need to meet people need to
retouch some respect on Vince Zampella
this man had producing credits for first
of all one of his first games he ever
produced was NBA Jam tournament
wow I didn't even know that
Wow so put some respect on that man for
that but he's got producer credits for
Medal of Honor no and call of duty one
call a day to call duty 3 call of duty 4
call me her mom work there too titanfall
five bikes
titanfall to apex legends this man has
not made a bagman you okay Courtney man
has done has been producing and
directing games since 1998 how come they
exploded him out of the building
no Bobby Kotick
you know how to an emcee that's the
nicest in the room you know say the
pseudonym supposed to be the boss feel
away I'm just trying to say he was
unfairly
from his position and taken out of the
door and and and I know I know and I
understand why right I felt that this is
his Redemption Song mmm
opposed to EA you know easy just happens
to be in a position where dice and a
frostbite engine is in the bushes
all right I'm putting it there putting
him in a position for it to be an EA
redemption that's what it is because
they fire cuz you know cuz the thing is
you know even when he was dead he came
in with that pedigree right and what did
they do they released battlefield 1 the
same day Oh bathroom form same day sign
for like literally one of the first
people that I can remember in recent
memory who's currently head of two
studios so technically the head of
Respawn Entertainment and he is now the
head of dice LA and they are working
they're ready working on a new project
they don't know what it is I'm putting
my money down it's a Medal of Honor game
again because I feel bad company or bad
company like let's face it battlefield
has become a bit of a meme with how dice
has handled it over the past you become
a bit of a joke they need
one to take it over and make it
competitive again because Col Beauty
came out just absolutely mopped the
floor with Maura warfare so they back on
their ball and what people don't
remember was Zampella is that that man
has a grudge with infinity named
bad blood a blood one split from
Infinity Ward there was a lot of really
nasty mud throwing that and like that
was what titanfall was all about is all
thanks I want to make a Call of Duty
killer
that was what Sam fellas mind sentencing
has always been like you see call duty
goes from the BAL Royale oh we got apex
legends this man is determined to be at
the top of the tier of what he is doing
and I think he will elevate dice and EA
to a new level and it's great to see EA
finally understanding yeah that when you
have good talent you let them do what
they need to do instead not tell you I
don't think that they realized anything
I think pegs legends made them looking
and even even more than Jedi I think we
appreciate Jedi because we wanted that
single player Star Wars experience but
it definitely is apex what said okay
they need to pay attention to this guy
because what's funny is uh I don't know
if you guys remember but when titanfall
2 came out he was low-key disgusted with
they dropped I think when they would to
purchase that company like they knew
they were going to give him a little bit
more keys to the kingdom than they would
normally do that's quite like the music
business man unless it's too much ok a
shout to fit to Alice Dean file awesome
chat with game and become the juggernaut
and Amazon are set to come next year do
you think EA and Activision could be
acquired
respawn would be right for hey oh dear
he disrespecting three-for-three he out
here for three for three Barry three for
three with their last joint Victor arm
as far as you know Amazon is coming I
don't know if they're gonna acquire
those two guys but you know they're
definitely gonna be aggressively in the
market we'll see but what I'm gonna get
is these bars listen man let's keep it
real EAS last two albums for the most
part on they own I was not
Vince related I was but yeah a second
drama and anthem was straight they went
double would well Adam did well
financially handsome financially but
well alright but what if they or did it
did yeah it did fine as well
I think it finished as one of the top
game selling games at a year what do
they count and returns
oh my we turn gain to get my money back
the money coming in are you telling the
money going out time is that game
supposed to be on anybody's list of
highly financially successful game how
much money got back today you know say
like they had was it's a beautiful thing
because two reasons one when one thing
about Vince is no one is gonna strong on
him that's what I love about like just
his history in the game he has been a
maverick in that sense early that's not
true cuz when they got him out of the
door they didn't strong-armed him and he
was the court he woke up and I respect
their modern warfare is one of the best
Call of Duty's ever that's when we
started paying players became one of
those people you have to call security
to get him out that let you uh yeah you
gotta go right now no get secured you
know they whispered in the courtroom
they show that videotape the end of the
day what I love about this song is that
he has such cachet now because they've
been dropping flops any a because
they've been not going against they've
been going to get single player
everything's been loop boxes
microtransactions right if you look at
his games they're not that you know for
the most part and like I said Jedi
proved the single player you know and
apex I'm not a battle
but I cannot front or not game changing
fundamentally a lot of concepts in the
battle royal John where people like yo
this is fire you know I'm saying so
those two games showed his cachet over
and then what I love about him is he's
like you know we not using your beats no
frostbite beats unreal we're doing this
cuz remember that's a problem with
anthem anthem had to fall in line and
first bite was extremely it was the
first part wasn't even designed to be a
fighter like that the fact that he can
beat to his own drum
he bass then get to success it forces
ESA yo we got about need this I do it is
on upward trend it this dude knows
what's going on out here and to give him
I feel like right now if they straighten
up if EA strains up next-gen it's all
cuz events what a big flow what podcast
did you listen to where he was talking
ill thing because of this time for
threes happening that's happened sure
before I was it was it was iffy oh
you're zippy but now is happy shout to
Jonathan B hashtag frostbite beats yeah
there's a piece of trash nobody was
liking though but not all Rick my
brother we getting you in a run with
2020 man was going off excellence in the
building us my dude easy what's going on
in Boston oh yeah Rick let us know man
that's the chap you're gonna be at and
Boston man packs brother it'll be great
to see you man definitely
friends in the realm but uh yeah that's
all I got the end of the day he's moving
out here this got the sauce man it's got
the sauce so it's good oh he's going
he's going so we must live listen so so
this time we're gonna Freud you with the
BS you gotta go we gotta sit down drink
yes I'm addicts off I'll let you finish
they ain't really much to finish up he
ain't been screwing up left and right
and Vince's like I'm taking control I'm
happy that he's in a position to control
his narrative and I'm so happy that he
threw that Frostbite engine in the
bushes I thought that they've made a a
multi-tool with the Frostbite engine
there we I don't know it was I think I
will pass out if that is true sir nah
Jonathan B we're not doing that for our
super Chad this might be memphis bleek
all in sight there because of your weed
not doing it what's funny is a lot of
these people are going crazy over one
game with CD Projekt RED got to be my
man but you not want to sell you know
what job can be i'll be i'll be in your
corner on coming of age I think bully
one anyway the slo-mo one man this has
way more than a cub of it slow dropping
and now let's move on Lord addict man
yeah I got a lot of hate over the so you
know Phil domina Spitzer
you know him in the game past team you
know they work to deal with Rockstar and
it looks like GTA 5 is now on gay peso
he got gay past unit you know for the
likes of three of you in the world that
haven't played that game you know
definitely go over there and download
that yes but I don't really want to talk
to so much about GTA 5 what I want to
talk about is do you guys think that
this kind of trend will continue because
I feel like regardless that this game is
old and it's really old I mean it came
out in the 360 air and was ported over
to the Xbox one do you think that will
get games like this caliber going
forward so I want to start with keen
with yeah you know I need I need game
pass emotes in that chat 2002 Ricky says
the best service in the business my man
good team that's right that's that's a
hell of a good game to put inside a game
pass I saw when you in deal it was going
back and forth and back and forth this
to to me it was more like I said
something he's something that I said no
he said something last you didn't see it
I sort of the old man late-night week
week it's just it's a great game to have
in there
so let's say somebody didn't purchase it
or they did I see the financial thing of
him maybe they started to take a dip and
say alright let's put in a service now
let's not front is on PlayStation now -
don't act up in the day after it left
people well right - it was at 12 weeks
on PS now the money you guys take it off
PlayStation Rockstar is cashing in in a
really smart way but yes we all know
game path gives you a 10% discount on
all those shortcuts all those sharp
cards people that already own GTA 5
I now have a 10% discount on their crack
money yeah that was that is crazy you
can go to your Dale if you like I got 2%
discount guard we do not see them once
you put the gang of that downloaded it
right that and of course you do
I never finish the game oh thank you for
um if you think about it when sold I
clicked on that game it showed me all
the bundles that you can get with this
game that's not included free Wow how is
that hustled a hustle is crazy like do
you want the expansion pack where you
can steal from the store so I'm like yes
I love that it's 2995 but you get the
10% discount Mikey boy y'all out here
really still in the pockets but it felt
like addicts said a game of this caliber
inside game paths only enhances the
service now let's say a new person comes
in that didn't get a chance to play that
and they said what that game is
available in game pass along with The
Witcher along with um you say what is
that Devil May Cry 5 along with all the
first party stuff a game past has been
enhancing its portfolio going forward
we're not just NIF not games then you
know they have their little in the
corner Indies but then they also have
those big bangers like these dudes be
talking about inside there and yeah you
can yell out it's old but it's new to
somebody else who's never touched it
yeah I mean I want to say this in in
finish though I gotta I gotta keep it
true we weren't popping bottles with
sodium you know whatever but I mean to
what I'm dead is saying I think that's a
great point that the real winner is
Rockstar right yeah they are you know
saying hey this it's like a double dip
and then you said like you said make a
great point King with the 10% and all
that but I guess my question I think
someone had shot the Iliad and it
he made a good point the question I want
to know though is we all feel gay past
one of the best service like we cannot
deny the value right it's what literally
one of the best services in gaming the
question has always been day and a
first-party but will there ever be a
time when there's day and date third
party right so my question in yours do
you think I know that's an older game
right we get it but do you think this
sets the precedence because the rumors
on the street is and I know one did I
know you've seen this room before is
cyberpunk I keep hearing that you're
saying so now we know you know there's a
relationship I guess and you know it's
debuted or on the stage on did you get
lots of loads of gaming knowledge here
like do you think it could possibly lead
to something like that or that's just
way too far-fetched and I dance in the
bushes so we go so there's a lot of
things that could play into this
CD Projekt RED is not gonna be hurting
at the launch of this game for money
because this game is gonna fly off the
shelves let's face it so probably be one
at the top five best song games of 2012
acts like it's gonna do numbers
especially with all the people are now
diving into The Witcher because of the
Netflix series everything else CD
Projekt RED it's saying they're just
throwing dollar bills around so they're
not hurting for money the thing is what
you gotta look at is if if cyberpunk was
to come to game pass if I was to if I if
I in a magical world still landed that
deal the way I would do it would be for
Xbox Series X is gonna come back holiday
2020 mmm-hmm cyber punks in the first
quarter of 2020 cuz I gave CD Projekt
RED six months of sales on it right
they'd have to wait go do we take the
bag from Microsoft to say X on the
launch of Xbox Series X you'll have a
halo infinite and cyberpunk 2077 day one
on launch enhanced on Xbox very relaxed
I don't know to me it makes sense but I
don't know how many bags and money
would have to throw its Projekt RED to
have to have it that's a lot of my hold
oh I got a gives in and no days I like
calling people
Zayn says CD Projekt RED deserves every
penny don't get it on game fat zing that
is doctrine as a misconception brother
they the dev is getting a bag we've
already wait wait wait what makes you
think you can't go and buy the game yeah
we had two tons studios yeah they're
just misconception that if a game is on
game pass that you're not supporting the
developer we've already disproved this
Lord they are getting a bag based on
what their anticipated number what
they're gonna sell on that so don't
think that you are not supporting the
dev because it's on Cape Town that is
not true continuing it yeah so I think
cyberpunk could happen in a crazy world
where they're trying to push the
kwang-ho
biggest console or most powerful console
we have ever seen I think an FPS game
over
like cyberpunk would be a good addition
to that and it would make a lot of sense
and I think we're gonna see some third
party deals if they're smart I think
we're gonna see cuz everyone knows the
biggest bum part about buying a new
console which God dropped the benig for
the content you've got drop the bag for
that launch line in one but how much of
that third-party launch lineup is Xbox
gonna be able to put in game pass that
becomes history I said it I said it the
last show before the break um this is
the first time we're going into a
console generation where I know I'm not
coming home with any discs right wait
game it's just game passed and Phil I
mean we'll talk about this in the next
segment if into those interview he said
it's like this is the first time we it
you're just gonna have game pass and
acid so we have to make sure that
transition is smooth but that's what it
is like that is your launch lineup is
this I think about that think about this
though think about how attract people
are under estimating how attracted it is
to get a brand new console with a
service that has over 100 semi games and
often a people keep in mind that I'm
confident that they're going to put a
lot of newer games
in that like day and day for the launch
the next Xbox like okay because they're
gonna want they're gonna want it to be
appealing but at the same time they
since it's gonna be new system they're
they're gonna want it to be refreshing
to you want the money I would say you
have you're gonna have halo obviously
right you're gonna have I think you have
something else rain [ __ ] I think you
have compulsions game maybe in in you're
gonna have a I'm assuming at least three
first party games in there day one and
by then we'll probably see gears tactics
to listen you're gonna have that
cyberpunk in there day and date and it's
not taken away from the development you
do about a game in the store I mean if
you don't game past it's in there for
you and you can still buy that game in
Microsoft Store you know maybe to be
there for six to eight months inside the
games do revolve and rotate the Russians
back on you again he said so you can get
it old date you won't catch this favor
let me let me show you something who did
their for you if you part of the you
know catch their face listen they want a
money back from Keano all right so you
talkie Anna was just a one-off you
thought they all these games that they
have shown on a summer jam screen way
into game past
oh so formal fashion they leave you the
breadcrumbs they leave you no cookies he
let me know what's that supposed to
chase a yo-yo while he said kid go hit
you with that game past shuffle don't
you start you already know when it's up
there on the screen it's coming every
post every last time it just phenols
games there they wind up in game paths
right
they've been there so they debuted at
game there they show they bring out
Keanu Reeves on the stage it's not
splashing to game pass balls it's gonna
be pretty so nice it's not beating you
know what King has a brilliant point too
because where everyone remembers there's
that video leak for a game pass
advertisements a Devil May Cry 5 with it
and a lot of us went nah Capcom ain't
gonna poke it showed up you know I think
I think what people aren't realize is I
remember writing the articles by year
and a half ago Mike Rhodes who works for
an independent publishing studio called
no more robots he was one of the first
people that said game passes garbage
it's gonna kill independents together
Muto this land oh hey and and you know
what Phil Spencer went got his game on
game press and they outperformed their
steam sales by icy's field as a gangster
boo but you go over there you embrace
your hater right you turn him around now
he's sitting me with the pom-poms out
bad-mouthing to God knock you out cold
anyway cup talk about game pass for
white we didn't mention this is the
length of time that these games stay in
game passes but the third-party so
obviously the first party stuff is
staying there right but devil may cry 5
is still in there right yo and rage to
all that still in there yep we didn't
mention what games other games left PS
now when GTA 5 left God of War oh and
uncharted 4 I don't know wow there's Ari
to break this did we get this I want to
jump in okay so we got a $5 super chat
from California Kid what do you guys
think of Phil releasing an only series
x4 399 and completely killing Sony
entire playerbase will be on the series
X what do you think about that King
well shut up to home California kid I
always see your tweets you always like
subscribe I love that
god bless um they will never do that for
that price
listen in a pipe dream yeah that's a
pipe dream but that's that's not
happening I don't want you guys to
really buckle down and understand that
these systems is going to cost you a
pretty penny under you let you know
there's no PC on the market for the
prices that they giving it to you for
that can do that type of tech so of
course they're gonna give it to you at a
price that they can tolerate that
they're gonna turn a profit these
companies are here to make money they're
not here to do anything for free they're
not your friends they're not your
buddies and not your pals right you
hired them it's your money that's
putting em towards you real quick save
what we love going at you you say King
who brought you the Xbox you currently
love I'll tell you who PlayStation 4
that butt-whipping they gave Xbox dis
generation you're not lying you telling
me the truth I was so fast it thrown my
regular Xbox in the bushes in the bush
is fast enough sir when I got that X
right now yes thank you for smacking
Phil in the face and waking up the Beast
that's crushing you right now and Matt
stop because you oh come up now you got
game pass on your neck look at you man
it's you right now y'all lost GTA 5 and
where's that and game pass is going to
become a norm just like Netflix
eventually is going to be on every home
because it's not just going to be for
council you didn't try to get a game
passing I just want to expound on
something undead said that I completely
didn't think about and um in terms of
cyberpunk and I thought about it like
sorry punk once the release date
officially what is it like April right
so it would make sense I think I don't
know if it'll go out right on launch
I think they'll let CD Projekt RED Rock
but I think it'd be the perfect game
pass launch on Ceres X by November right
good then they get then you still get
bread then they get another bag they say
now if you buy a series X think about
that you if I was to true to be true
you'd have handle infinite most likely a
Forza game maybe a gears tactic and
cyberpunk as your launch like that would
be kind of crazy four-game pass for
Series X as a storm so I mean I could
see that type of scenario possibly if it
does come to game pass but that's what I
got you know say if anybody got anything
else left on attics topic if not we
gonna move King King up any of you I
feel Dominus recently man a lot of gems
being drop you wanted to talk about
alright so I'm just recently on Larry
herb show for the Christmas send-off or
the holiday send-off let's say the
holiday because they're celebrating
Hanukkah Kwanzaa everything on the one I
love Larry y'all know I love Larry Daley
Larry always shouts me out every time he
sees me and I think that level of
remembering somebody or whatever is
endearing to me so I should be Larry
with the utmost respect the show is
fantastic cog made sure that I watched
his show or listen to the show and Phil
was on the show now remember those
remember guys and when I was telling you
about leaks and every time Microsoft
always seen the one that they always had
the leaks out and you never can get the
foot and they can never surprise anyone
and the biggest surprise that they have
and everybody's been saying that
Microsoft has turned the corner because
nobody knew that X was coming at the
award show nobody saw it coming and when
you listen to Phil talk about how they
were so secretive with it
how they sat down with different
partners how they ran a screen in the
background and they put it on the loop
so nobody can actually tell exactly
what's going on and he said it was
ingenious and how they were doing it it
was kind of like some loose like a James
Bond that type of thing to keep that
level of entry up and
surprise when a company feels that way
that they want to show you a surprise
they want to bring something to you it's
remember this is his first hassle under
him and all those other consoles was
iterations of somebody else's idea this
tech is his tech so of course he once
said with the same loving kid he wants
to present it how he want to present it
and it got there in foolish and I'm
saying now after listening to that
interview has Microsoft turned that
corner in being that cohesive company
that they were before they always seemed
like loose and aloof and right now they
seem laser focus did they change did you
listen to the interview what was your
thoughts on interviewer and what did you
take from it well let me go first cuz I
have to leave here in a couple seconds
but um one thing I think Microsoft
really what's where I'm looking for
they started evaluating is I think the
leaks hurt them a lot in the past
for instance the Master Chief collection
at that one got leaked it that would
have been a really big surprise a lot of
people think that that the XO of 2018
was wasn't the greatest but let's be
real here the biggest information was
leaked Obsidian being bought you know
exile being bought imagine that that
wouldn't got leaked so I feel like
that's the reason they're moving a
little bit more direction to making sure
that their actual news doesn't get
leaked from the third party yeah I mean
I think I gotta go you guys thanks
everyone coming by and I'll see you guys
next week yeah I think you know when it
comes to tech right tech you wonder why
isn't the movie industry so secretive
right why is it always gaming always
been so secretive and I think when it
comes to any time I'm talking about a
tech release whether it's hardware or
whether it's a game um people are very
protective of that right the companies
are very protective of that and
rightfully so because you know if
somebody gets a hold of your tech
they can release something utilizing it
you know six months before you do
whatever the case may be so it's
something that they have to be cognizant
of and and like adequate saying like
there were a lot of big announcements
that got leaked early that it kind of
took the wind out of those sails a
little bit so I like the fact that they
what they've had to do it's kind of sad
that they have to do things like you
know fake scripts and things like that
and tell as few people as possible so
that they can keep secrets but I think
you know I think it's imperative and I
think if us as gamers we love those
secrets like we you know whatever
whatever we say about we should know
about this well I won't miss coming out
I like when they when they surprise me
with something I love that and you know
aside from like you know Nintendo has
always kept things bottled up but you
know the people they keep people locked
up in the treehouse that's a bummer Jose
Otero boogie-down only comes out of the
treehouse for holiday reform torn the
super chat violence which a game past
games day and date are normally from
first party developers if cyberpunk is
day and date that could be because
Microsoft for quiet about week running
with these polish rumors we have you
know we had a after party we they've had
smaller games they in date it's happened
right um so that it's happened with
smaller games that will continue to
happen with smaller games and see our
first big third party day and day
release you know we kind of saw it with
outer worlds but that's the I was
cheating that's there is everybody good
I did I said you cook it was up what you
think about this big yeah well first of
all the CD Projekt people need to stop
looking at them and start looking at for
a games when for a games gets acquired
by Microsoft and suddenly everyone loves
those metro games come call me a real
ass one of those games have a pet and a
relationship is really good well well
metro Exodus was the game they debuted
the Xbox one X with their like this is
listen and it was like what good work
screen was it on
that would be the the Xbox they showed
it on that Summer Jam screen I get and
you remember what it was part of the
trailer it was part of the run-through
it was part of the lead-up and where is
the game they doesn't give you the
breadcrumbs mmm like there's gonna be I
think Microsoft as a whole this is the
first time the Xbox division since its
founding all the way back to Wayne was
Seamus blackly this has been the first
time where Microsoft has believed in
something wholeheartedly and the Xbox
division isn't just the kid tinkering
with their toys on the side like if you
anyone reads back into the history of
the OG xbox that was an uphill fight 99%
of the time to get any kind of money and
they had to do some really crazy stuff
did you get that car did you hear what
Seamus put out about the dog different
today
he made Seamus put ice like I never told
anybody this but he was like he was one
of the biggest you know blockers C
blockers the selling that you know in
terms of getting the OG xbox released
because he didn't believe in Microsoft
even being in gaming and he says how
ironic it was that he ended up being in
the position that he didn't even believe
in later on during the 360 era and that
blew the internet and then um shout to
Ryan McCaffrey and the follow-up tweet
to that he co-signed that he was like
yeah we knew about that and he was
trying to get the dawn on the show to
talk about he said but even him dodged
him like the plague he could never get
him one as advertised my love man to
Phil Dominus Maximus Spencer for taking
control of the situation
and we start at 8:00 in my xbox because
if Xbox is my Sega ok sega siga died and
what do we have left over fill the void
Microsoft they my company that we want
it but that's the company that we got
and how did they showing the love that
Sega had that Sega brand and their love
they didn't get to
with those iconic games yet with such a
Halo and Gears and Forza and I know COG
is sick and tired of the happy meal
fries and cake type of me yeah man yeah
man did his thing don't listen
they'll came out Dominus came out I
still think and we get to me on it I
think that move was probably during his
run one of his the top three moves I put
that up there probably say number one I
would say back compact was a strong move
from him game pass announcement in
itself but series X with hell-blade is
probably his shining moment so far out
of a key moment sort of filter that's
just my personal pain but the biggest
moment for xbox this generation that no
one is going to remember and no one will
remember this because it's a financial
backdrop issue was the firing and
removal of Terry bison you look at the
look at what Xbox is done from the Feist
since the firing of Terry Myerson
but this dope those dudes it was him and
done oh there was yeah there was open
back
yeah that's Patrick didn't wanna be in
the gaming sphere in the first place and
Meyerson thought it was a waste of time
arson believed more in Windows Phones as
phone who's in the bushes so I gave yet
people get fill a lot of credit I mean
crap but at the end of the day you you
can make the argument he's literally
fought for the existence of the Xbox
branded to prove to Sasha that not only
is it valuable that if we're gonna do it
we gotta go all-in right and he's
getting them to buy in with the services
with game paths and you know Microsoft
like money you know it's got listen they
got accountants everywhere bad if this
thing ain't doing well for them
financially they would not be doing this
so it is something to be said but
continue I did I completely agree with
all the things you're saying about Terry
Myerson and that hold that house up and
this this is the thing is why I feel
like I I hate to use hyperbole a lot but
this isn't the Xbox brand that I grew up
on with the 360 or anything else if I
came in on the 360 air not the og air
the og era
he was one of the best areas of Xbox for
diversity of content the Japanese games
are on there were phenomenal yes and
there's a lot of classic games that are
lost back there because of deals that
can't be made anymore or weren't being
made but seeing seeing the deals that
Phil's making and like this isn't even
like if you take the console war
nonsense out of it just the fact that
we're gonna see a Yakuza game on an Xbox
console we're seeing Final Fantasy games
are on Xbox going forward like yeah -
c71 makes gonna be on PlayStation for a
year but we all know what's coming to
Xbox mm-hmm in the end of the day we're
seeing games that used to not come to
this ecosystem at all and they are
coming to this ecosystem and not only
are they coming into this ecosystem
these Japanese developers that have been
so hard to get deals with are putting
these games into game pass mm-hmm the
games are going into game pass this
means a couple of things obviously game
pass provides values to developers
obviously to obviously Japanese
developers are starting to see enough
interest in the Xbox ecosystem to invest
in this ecosystem mm-hmm and number
three is that many people have been
yelling from the roof since 2014 I know
I have I know almost everyone on this
panel has to of diversifying the games
is here we have the largest lineup of
Xbox games coming in 2020 that eclipses
2017 2018 and 2019 combine whole don't
know what even if you don't want all
those games there is something there for
you if you're saying there's not I don't
know what to tell you hold on I gotta
get what dick bonds tend on super jab my
brother Lords of gaming got net tech
guru Phil Dominus gen is starting
holiday 22 ready no doubt that undead it
was there was like a few naysayers I
predominantly agree with you there were
a few naysayers in the chat when you
were speaking they said oh no Russian
says money only moves or doesn't when
the Sachin Adele and Amy Hood approved
myosin II have nothing to doing it
that's the first thing and then beats
game and lives in he says Don Mattrick
was a beast he is the 360 his screw-up
was connected to your so what do you say
to those people who say
we need to roll it back instead of a
date so refresh my memory who was the
money man
that took over three who was head of 360
was that mm-hmm you got hell was that
I'm sure I remember he's the guy who did
the gta4 tattoo Oh will you talk about
doing the three said give me my man you
mean it to God you mean you mean um
there homie with the tattoo you talk
about Oh from sega zone I'm witty beat
up beat him up it beater more the legend
more was the reason the 360 was amazing
people need to stop giving magic planet
Patrick inherited a ship that was
already the reason why you should see
the Xbox one failed was because all
matric did was sit on the moral bright
day my brother talked about could you
please teach him right now because I
don't think he understands classes in
session faster to your mic and just the
reason why we stumbled his finger we
inherited something that Peter wall
already built to greatness because you
Peter ball was a Sega kid he said he was
mad that the Dreamcast lost to Sony you
know saying he was mad that he died off
so when he signed up with Microsoft that
was his goal he was focused on that
generation the fiery dude yes we do
continue Moore was the guy that went you
know how we you know what made the 360
great content more new content was king
fact and that's what he did all that
like that gta4 moment is like one of the
most legendary previous generation
moments everyone heroes have to know for
I remember losing my mind on that that
was mad stupid mothers he was there and
he was hungry and the matric inherited
it and went oh oh this'll just self run
itself that's why we had first party
game made by third party studios we had
all this things that all blew up in the
face of Xbox in 2013 was because matric
went and this will work mm-hmm people
need a hailing a trick question
God is he inherited I'd be like if I
came in and took over kognito role in
iron Lords podcast
I took over this way yeah look at this
thing I built that's not how this works
you are based on the merits of what you
do with me after time you have it it's
the same reason why I will always say
Kaz Hirai was the best thing that ever
happened to PlayStation is that the
PlayStation 3 and made it usable made
people actually love is like hey love
this thing there's games he's roasting
his toes going I did to console
generations of this crap I'm good no
shadow job to be said while undead
talking he said we did it church organ
playing behind I have advices ever since
magic took over we stopped getting
hardcore games he was pushing more
connective and member TV TV everyone
forgets the reason why it's called the
Xbox one is because it's all in one that
was the whole purpose of a name like the
Xbox one all-in-one entertainment system
you could do the same stuff with your
PlayStation but they weren't like a ps1
all-in-one do basketball game live TV oh
is this man going to us right now if if
this doesn't fit your nature we got the
system for you the classic classic way
to yeah I completely agree with you how
did you preach in you know I'm saying
and then oh yeah but we got to see we
got to see what's gonna go on but um I
do agree with what King I thought
filling that interview dropped so many
gems from I liked his energy his energy
was cool calm he was having fun he said
a lot of cool things in reference to the
announcement and not one thing we got to
admit like in order for him to have that
moment it can't be a leak because if
there's a leak that changes the whole
conversation and dynamic of watching the
game Awards if we know coming into the
game award there's a strong chance let's
your and out
salute the RAM we had a show it was hit
unless you read that new Nvidia put it
but a good guess on you know the impact
that had that no one knew and the fact
that like King said he went through
those lengths doing a fake script right
and one of the cool things if you listen
to the interview he says it was actually
suggested I forgot the lady need to
check on the team I forgot salute her
and I think you ever get my man he never
gave her name but he said it was
suggested during the meetings about when
to reveal the series X and I think there
was there's some talk that XO could have
had it you know I'm saying other
shoulder well they said XO was supposed
to get a hell blade well to get hell
blade right right so for them to for him
to have the foresight to say you know
what you might be onto something was a
ballsy move in that rep to me is bigger
than what people are giving it credit
for because it represents something that
I've always complained about Microsoft
which is knowing that theatrics know on
the moment
that's what Sony Nintendo do right I've
always complained and that's why for me
the series exit announcement of
hell-blade is the biggest moment for
them to start the new generation cuz
that pure except everybody's watching
everybody's reactions trailers now right
you go right to that moment and you want
to see what people were like people were
going crazy there came in I believe
you're onto something cuz she was new
you have to understand that this man
didn't exude hubris over her by you know
she's new she raises her hands nervous
there and she's like how about you know
we put it inside the awards show if
takes a little yeah if Phil is a is not
a democratic ruler of like an emperor
he's if number like sitting I'm gonna
cry we don't do it that way he sat back
and he was like maybe she's right you
know it's a different type of person to
sit back and to listen to everybody
that's there because you have faith in
your team and it shows while me watching
the interview listening to the interview
it just shows that the
a little bit more connected than before
like you said it's a different like from
top to bottom he know he has the
financial backing with these dudes he
knows that
let's just let's give a round of
applause to our kidding yes
all right because killed them all form
in each other right we've killed them
and marketing has been spot-on and they
didn't change anybody in marketing Oh
was it them being undermined that's well
mm-hmm you know when it was when the
leaks and stuff was going out you just
have to look at it as a whole as they
didn't just turn over they remove two
people out of key positions that fix the
company and put people in place like you
said cut going into this next generation
there's no going to the store picking up
a ton of games a path that changes the
narrative on how everything is moving
how how we're going forward everybody I
need to take notice this is going to be
a change for us going for the digital
era is going to be this year mm-hmm
first time is in full effect first time
is the fact that this and nobody's
scared right 2013 everybody's terrified
doing here I mean I was in but they won
I bought everything on disk I said I
don't think it's gonna work mm it would
have worked
everything was fairly smooth when it
launched in terms of at least being able
to download the games but you know I
have my discs I was happy whatever but
this time is like wow I'm going to pick
up the box and that's it and that's it
you'll start to Philly eager to make it
a good point file a super check been
saying it a while this is the first time
Xbox has been run by a gamer it feels
different because it is different now
it's go time
no perfectly said man I mean you
definitely again Phil doesn't get enough
credit now I get I be the four King has
been on the field ominous train and I've
been specs gonna go you know I'm a Peter
Moore guy I've always admitted it but I
have to admit you know just to see the
momentum carrying on now from the how
a degeneration started to him picking up
the pieces changing the narrative taking
things away you know getting this thing
buying the studios you know now leading
into this next generation it has Xbox
fans excited and you have to credit him
for that so it's good keep it up
hopefully no more leaks you know keep
the ship tight whoever they look like
they know who the snitches are you know
they're so out here with misinformation
he knows is you you don't say so that's
what's up now all we need to see is the
games you know I'm saying so he'll blade
was a great start single-player dark
mature narrative beautiful star that's
what Xbox game has been wanting to see
let's keep the momentum let's see what
the other Studios are working on
playground initiative compulsion all
those guys and he even said that an
interview he said yo people are sleeping
on compulsions I'm dying to know what do
they those guys cooking up we know
undead we had to leave it there body
adequately they're both on compulsion
fans so we will see and you know
hopefully we may hear something from
compulsion so that's all I got
we go wrap up and get this poll going
you know I'm saying so new ILP poll this
week with the rumors of a possible
PlayStation 5 reveal at CES what do you
think is the best possible event to
rebut the Xbox series X at the Gabe
Awards the choices are a CES 2020 more
national spotlight of PS 5 to the
electronic world big a splash be
revealed PlayStation 5 at your own Sony
dedicated event completely controlled a
narrative or see I don't care
9 teraflops don't want it with the whole
12 teraflop Tower of Power Rock the Vote
when it goes up or the IO feet which are
probably Tuesday salute undead salute
the Attic who had to bounce out shout
the pics ooh big G $2 super chat preach
and tell them Xbox is serious this
generation you already know it looks
good so far hopefully they keep the
momentum your ass out the fuzzy
Belvedere no doubt but Nord sub back for
the new year IOP 2020
wicked
people find you what do you have going
on sir nothing gotta go to work but you
know you can calm me on Twitter and I
stopped Opie and you can find me at a
PSN xbox live BX sovereign oh no doubt
and of course Lord King back in 2020
shooting shot letting the haters know
what time it is wicked if I move on she
was going on her from the game purse
shuffle alright so y'all know Kos was on
vacation to me because I just I couldn't
have cog working on this time thank you
sir
pull my collar to some man I think my
legs is running baby so you know
definitely Texas dry so a lot of times
you guys speak to somebody on home you
get a better feel of things but um Kos
is coming back this week like I said I'm
waiting for one that I'm in and then I'm
gonna give y'all that DC blow out pause
that y'all been asking for I'm a little
deep dive into all these DC characters
those books that you see over there is a
books that I got from sideshow during
the holidays specially it was like on
half off or something like that and one
of them is the anatomy of a metahuman
and you know they call them metahumans
in DC and I think the anatomy of the
villains so that's why you see the Joker
that's in the front I think that's one
of the best six scale toys you know like
glad you join - yeah he is very nice
toys are very nice those are actual
dollars in our statues and I'm yeah the
difference and i'ma show you the price
wise had these for a long time so it's
gonna be nice to do that with you guys
and talk over that oh we have a lot of
fights this year so your combat talk
with the King is gonna be up somebody
asked me what was my name on Xbox Live
follow me on twitter is king david OTW
exact thing oh yeah you're not gonna be
the same exact king
[Laughter]
very friendly
that's a different game on the show my
kids watch my family watches and this
show is also the preferred listening
down time for Mount Vernon children that
they this is one of the preferred
listening channels on YouTube that
they're they're gonna allow them to
listen to the podcast you know when they
have downtime and I take that and I hold
that in very high regard because if your
children can listen to us without us
cursing without us being derogatory
without you know bad things happening
and they can take that and learn from it
I'm pleased with that so um listen being
a car listening to us with your children
you don't have any fear but you flipping
out doing something crazy
rental advisory gig l-boogie David King
don't play with you shout the punch like
it's finally watch it live since you
guys changed a time with a podcast for
me Logan yes no it's just I'm so happy
that we're back I'm so happy for the two
hundred plus people that were here with
us at a new time coming back that they
meet that speaks a lot I missed you as
much as you missed us and next week
we're gonna come bigger better badder
and wait pause also salute to gwg in the
building we got ladies of gaming they're
coming up on their 100th episode
l-boogie lady infamous there in the
chair they're big supporters of the
realm we still got a collab with Charlie
I gotta give us a date but to still be
working with char we want to do the
ladies of the realm and I LP you know
I'm sorry but please salute them they're
coming up on 100 episodes Saturdays is
when they go I believe it is 12 p.m.
Eastern so 9 p.m. Pacific
check them out great bunch of gaming
salute Oh Delilah HD as well as on the
team Charisse they are really cool and
Industry please support them and the
Lord's always salute the ladies of the
realm so that's that and I'm yeah
everybody man 1 o'clock - you know 2020
be back out here is good to see y'all
still rocking us over 200 in a chat
really appreciate you I really feels
good and uh we got a lot of things
cooking y'all twenty twenties gonna be a
fun year for the Lord's we really
respect y'all and Lords and once again
with that net how can I not forget
everybody got a biggest hugest month and
then you saw undead in the building he's
one of the people responsible you're I'm
saying you already know the vibes on
that V case vents I like that it is
there but yeah it's been tremendous man
and again it's due to you guys let's do
the support so when you see those
articles even if you don't agree
comments say you don't like it just puts
a bit there because the writers that we
have Wow this team is instrumental very
proud to be what's up I do a giveaway on
their Kara okay um on the channel for
like one of the statues of Kos coming up
I might if y'all Intel Kara let me once
with a got enough of response of it you
know I might do a giveaway on that I
think that thing is worth like $500 now
everybody that's it
enjoy your playoff Sunday you know
saying so he was going on and we will be
back in the round next week that's all I
got everybody enjoy your Sunday we are
out peace